This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Around the world, when you ask people what keeps them awake at night, they'll invariably tell you, money problems. Our challenges with money are varied, but we generally tend to have a fixed way of thinking about them. Most of us point to external factors as the root cause of our money problems. We've had an eight-day losing streak in the Dow that in percentage terms puts it on par close to that percentage loss those two days in 1929. This could be the most serious recession in decades.
这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦达兰坦。在世界各地，当你问人们是什么让他们夜不能寐时，他们无一例外都会说是金钱问题。我们与金钱的冲突形形色色，但我们对这些问题的看法往往有一种固定的思维模式。我们大多数人都把外部因素当作金钱问题的根源。道琼斯指数连续八天下跌，按百分比计算，这与1929年那两天将近的百分比跌幅不相上下。这可能是几十年来最严重的经济衰退。
Every American is feeling the bite of inflation. Groceries cost more, gas costs more, everything seems to cost more. It's certainly true that a recession or an unexpected medical expense can send our finances into a tailspin. But it's also the case that psychological factors within us can play a powerful role in determining our financial successes and failures. All I know is I have these beliefs around money that are banging around in my subconscious and in our studies we have found that these beliefs, most of us aren't even
每个美国人都感受到了通货膨胀的压力。杂货变贵了，汽油变贵了，似乎什么都变贵了。经济衰退或意料之外的医疗费用确实会让我们的财务状况陷入混乱。但同样真实的是，我们内心的心理因素在决定我们财务上的成功与失败方面发挥着强大的作用。我只知道，我有一些关于金钱的信念在我的潜意识里盘旋，而在我们的研究中我们发现，这些信念——我们大多数人甚至都没有
really aware of them, they have a profound impact on our financial outcomes. on our financial outcomes. Today we begin a new series called Money 2.0. Over the next few weeks, we'll explore how money shapes our behavior in profound and subtle ways. We'll consider how money influenced the rise of civilizations and why we're drawn to focus on people who are richer than us. We'll also look at the common psychological traps that lead to money difficulties and how we can chart a path to solid financial footing. Our money and our minds, this week on Hidden Brain. Many of us struggle with money. We have a hard time saving it. We spend more than we earn
真正意识到它们——对我们的财务结果有着深远的影响。对我们的财务结果。今天，我们开始一个名为“金钱2.0”的新系列。在接下来的几周里，我们将探讨金钱如何以深刻而微妙的方式塑造我们的行为。我们将探讨金钱是如何影响文明崛起的，以及为什么我们会被那些比我们富有的人吸引。我们还将探讨导致金钱困难的常见心理陷阱，以及我们如何规划一条通往坚实财务基础的道路。金钱与我们的心灵，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。我们许多人都为金钱苦恼。我们很难存下钱。我们的花销超过了收入
and we blow through budgets. Others of us have the opposite problem, focusing so much on saving for the long term that we never commit to spending on things that will give us pleasure in the shorter. One thing we don't do? Few of us stop to think about how we think about money. We don't notice the psychological patterns in our behavior. That's why each money challenge can look like a brand new problem. Psychologist Brad Clans studies how people think about money. It turns out that once you understand the underlying patterns that shape your money-related
而且总是把预算花光。其他人则有相反的问题，他们把过多的精力放在长期储蓄上，以至于从不肯花钱在那些能在短期内带给我们快乐的事情上。我们没有做的一件事是什么？很少有人停下来思考我们是如何看待金钱的。我们没有注意到自己行为中的心理模式。这就是为什么每一个金钱挑战看起来都像是一个全新的问题。心理学家布拉德·克朗茨研究人们如何看待金钱。事实证明，一旦你了解了塑造你与金钱相关行为的潜在模式
behaviors, it can transform the way you think about your finances. Brad Clans, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Brad, I want to start by looking at a moment in your own life. You were just out of grad school and you had a massive amount of debt. I think you were staring at a $100,000 student loan. Can you start by telling me what it felt like to owe so much money?
它就能改变你对财务的看法。布拉德·克朗茨，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。布拉德，我想从你生活中的某个时刻开始聊起。你刚读完研究生，背负着巨额债务。我想你当时正盯着一笔10万美元的学生贷款。你能先告诉我欠这么多钱是什么感觉吗？
I knew that the only way for me to get through school was to take on loans. And I was very fortunate in undergrad that I had some sports scholarships and academic scholarships. But grad school was very expensive. And I knew that was the only way for me to get where I wanted to go, so I took on that debt and staring at that, looking at that interest rate,
我知道完成学业的唯一方法就是贷款。我很幸运，在读大学时拿到了一些体育奖学金和学术奖学金。但读研究生非常贵。我知道这是我实现目标的唯一途径，所以我背上了这笔债务，盯着那个利率，
it was terrifying for me, and it was something that I was very anxious to tackle and try to get rid of as fast as I could. Now, you had a friend of the time who was making a lot of money. What kind of amounts are we talking about here? Well, I saw him make over the course of a year about $100,000 by day trading.
这让我感到害怕，我非常渴望去解决它，并尽我所能以最快速度摆脱它。当时你有一个朋友赚了很多钱。我们说的是什么金额？嗯，我看到他通过日内交易，在一年多的时间里赚了大约10万美元。
And what was his secret when you watched him? What was he doing? What was so attractive about it to me is that he had no idea what he was doing. I would sit there and... Yeah, and I knew he had no idea what he was doing. I would sit there and, yeah, and I knew I had no idea either. So I sat there and I'd watch him buy a stock, and one that comes to mind is like EMC, and I'm like,
当你看着他时，他的秘密是什么？他在做什么？对我来说，它非常有吸引力的地方在于，他根本不知道自己在做什么。我会坐在那里……对，而且我知道他根本不知道自己在做什么。我会坐在那里……对，而且我知道自己也不知道。所以我坐在那里，看着他买入一只股票，脑海里浮现的一个例子比如是EMC，然后我说，
what's EMC? And he's like, I have no idea, click, and he buys a bunch. And this strategy had been extremely effective for him over the course of this year. So your friend is raking in the cash, even though he doesn't know what he's doing. He's buying and selling stocks and companies he's never heard of. Meanwhile, you're working three jobs. I understand you had lawn furniture inside your home. You're sleeping on the floor.
什么是EMC？他说，我不知道，点击，然后他买了一大堆。在这一年里，这个策略对他非常有效。所以你的朋友正在大把捞钱，尽管他根本不知道自己在做什么。他在买卖那些他从未听说过的公司的股票。与此同时，你打着三份工。据我了解，你家里放着草坪家具。你睡在地板上。
Obviously, I can imagine the next thought that goes through your head, Brad. Well, absolutely. And it really was, for me, the focus I was very honed in on getting rid of this debt, because I knew this was a big monkey on my back. And the interest rate was like eight and a half percent at that time. And so I thought, I saw this was a viable way for me
显然，布拉德，我可以想象你脑海中闪过的下一个想法。嗯，完全是这样。对我来说，我的注意力非常集中在摆脱这笔债务上，因为我知道这是一个压在我身上的巨大包袱。当时利率大约是百分之八点五。所以我想，我看到了这是一个切实可行的途径，让我
to just clean the slate and my goal was to get to a net worth of zero. That was my goal. Mm-hmm. How did you go about doing it? I mean, where did you generate the capital to begin day trading? Yeah, I didn't have much money, but what I did have was a truck. And the truck was worth probably about $7,000 at the time.
能够一笔勾销债务，我的目标是让净资产达到零。这就是我的目标。嗯哼。你是怎么做到的？我的意思是，你从哪里筹集资金来开始日内交易的？嗯，我没有多少钱，但我有一辆卡车。当时那辆卡车大概值7000美元左右。
So I decided to sell it and take the money and start trading with it. It just made logical sense from that point of view. It's like, of course I should do this. And I was living in Hawaii at the time and I didn't have a lot of material needs and I bought a couple of $500 cars. And I would, the reason I bought two is because the first one broke down in the first month
所以我决定把它卖掉，拿着这笔钱开始交易。从那个角度来看，这完全符合逻辑。就像是，我当然应该这么做。我当时住在夏威夷，没有太多的物质需求，我买了两辆500美元的汽车。我买两辆的原因是第一辆在一个月内就抛锚了
and I bought another one. And I would alternate fixing one and driving the other. And I thought this was totally fine. I can totally do this for a year so I can become wealthy or at least make that 100K to pay off my student loans. Did you have any success when you began day trading? Did you have moments where you suddenly felt,
我又买了一辆。我轮流修一辆、开另一辆。我觉得这完全没问题。我完全可以这样过一年，这样我就可以变得富有，或者至少赚到那10万块来还清我的学生贷款。当你开始日内交易时，你取得过什么成功吗？有没有哪个时刻让你突然觉得，
oh my gosh, this easy money is rolling in? I did. It was incredible. I had three months of just bliss watching these stocks that I was buying move up in value. And I think by the time I cobbled together savings and all that, I think I had about 10,000 in. And I remember vividly just seeing it go up, you know, 500, a thousand a month. And I knew that if I could get better at this, I would have no problem reaching my goal
天哪，这些容易赚到的钱正滚滚而来？我有过。这简直太不可思议了。我有三个月的时间，只是看着我买的这些股票一路上涨，简直幸福极了。我想，等我凑齐了积蓄之类的时候，我大概投入了1万美元。我至今仍历历记得，看着它上涨，你知道的，一个月涨500、1000。我知道如果我能在这方面变得更好，我在一年内达到目标就完全没有问题了。
within a year. So you must have felt that you made the right call to sell your truck, you know, quit your jobs, become a day trader. How did the story turn out? Well, unfortunately for me, but I think fortunately in retrospect, given that this experience launched my entire interest in financial psychology was about three months into it, the tech bubble burst. So I had invested at just about the peak of the tech bubble and I started to then watch
所以你当时一定觉得卖掉卡车、辞掉工作、成为一名日内交易员是一个正确的决定。后来这个故事是怎么发展的？嗯，对我不幸的是，但回顾过去我认为也是幸运的，因为这段经历引发了我对金融心理学的全部兴趣——大约在三个月后，科技泡沫破裂了。所以我投资时差不多正值科技泡沫的巅峰，然后我开始眼睁睁地看着
my accounts go down and stocks go down and I went to my friend and I'm like, what do I do and he's like, I have no idea. He's never experienced this. And I'd say over the course of three to six months, I mean, I was down about 70, 80%, and when it was all set and done, I'm gonna say about 90% of it was gone.
我的账户缩水，股票下跌，我去找我的朋友说，我该怎么办？他说，我不知道。他从未经历过这种情况。我想在三到六个月的时间里，我的资产缩水了大约70%到80%，当尘埃落定的时候，我要说大约90%的钱都没了。
You know, the question I asked myself was, why would a reasonably intelligent person do something so stupid with his money? Fortunately, being trained as a clinical psychologist, I had gotten here in a very logical way, as I knew that it could make sense if I analyzed it and learned from it. Brad, you fell for what was essentially a get rich quick scheme.
你知道，我当时问自己的问题是，为什么一个相当聪明的人会用自己的钱做出这么愚蠢的事？幸运的是，由于受过临床心理学训练，我是以一种非常合乎逻辑的方式走到这一步的，因为我知道如果我对其进行分析并从中吸取教训，这是说得通的。布拉德，你掉进了一个本质上是快速致富的骗局。
And of course, it's not just you. This happens all the time. I remember some time ago, people began buying stock in a company called GameStop. This was a company that was failing, but some traders on Reddit wanted to drive up the value of the stock. So they invested tens of thousands of dollars and the stock skyrocketed.
当然，不仅是你。这种事一直在发生。我记得一段时间前，人们开始购买一家名为游戏驿站的公司的股票。这是一家正在走下坡路的公司，但一些Reddit上的交易员想要推高股价。于是他们投资了数万美元，股价随之飙升。
It went from, I think, four dollars a share to $325 a share or some astronomical number like that. Here's a clip from CNN's Christine Romans. The fundamentals of the company have been rough here. They're not making any money. They've been closing stores. Someone's going to be hurting when this thing turns. But for now, it's not turning.
我记得它从每股4美元飙升到了每股325美元，或者是诸如此类天文数字般的水平。这是CNN的克里斯蒂娜·罗曼斯的一段节目片段。这家公司的基本面一直很糟糕。他们没有赚钱。他们一直在关店。当局势逆转时，有人要吃苦头了。但目前，局势还没有逆转。
Eventually, of course, Brad did turn. Some people made massive profits, but many others lost a lot of money. So clearly, your story is not the first time we've heard a story about a Get Rich Quick Scheme, and it's almost certainly not going to be the last. Yeah, there's nothing worse than the idea of hard work and drudgery and waiting years and discipline to become wealthy. And so anything that looks like it could be a shortcut, of course, it's like instantly attractive to most of us.
当然，最终，布拉德，局势逆转了。有些人赚取了巨额利润，但许多其他人失去了大笔金钱。所以很明显，你的故事并不是我们听到的关于快速致富骗局的第一个故事，而且几乎可以肯定它不会是最后一个。嗯，没有什么比辛苦工作、日复一日的苦差事、等待多年以及靠纪律来致富这个想法更糟糕的了。因此，任何看起来像是捷径的东西，对我们大多数人来说，当然都是瞬间具有吸引力的。
So Getrich Quicks schemes are not the only money problems that people confront. The average American has a credit card balance of $5,525. And collectively, Americans owe about three quarters of a trillion dollars in credit card debt. That's a heart-stopping number, Brad. It's an unbelievable number. And I remember the statistics showed that when we are in really good economic shape, that's when we tend to have the higher credit card debt and the lower savings rates. It's really fascinating.
所以快速致富骗局并不是人们面临的唯一金钱问题。美国家庭的平均信用卡余额为5525美元。总体而言，美国人背负着大约七千五百亿美元的信用卡债务。这是一个让人心惊肉跳的数字，布拉德。这是一个令人难以置信的数字。我记得统计数据显示，当我们的经济状况真正良好时，往往也是我们的信用卡债务较高、储蓄率较低的时候。这真的很有趣。
When we're really excited about things, we go into more of a spending frenzy, not really thinking about the future. This optimism that everything's going to be fine. And so we see that. I mean, that's the biggest problem in America, I believe, is not saving thinking about the future, this optimism that everything's going to be fine. And so we see that. I mean, that's the biggest problem America, I believe, is not saving enough for the future and spending more than we make. So the challenge of overspending seems like a simple enough problem to fix. I want to play you a clip from Saturday Night Live that essentially was a parody of the
当我们对事情感到非常兴奋时，我们会陷入一种更加疯狂的消费状态，而不再真正考虑未来。这种盲目乐观的情绪认为一切都会好起来的。所以我们看到了这一点。我的意思是，我认为美国最大的问题不是为未来存够钱，而是盲目乐观地认为一切都会好起来。所以我们看到了这一点。我的意思是，我认为美国最大的问题不是为未来存够钱，以及花销超过收入。因此，过度消费的挑战看起来是一个足够简单、容易解决的问题。我想播放一段《周六夜生活》的节目片段，它本质上是对这个
problem. Did you know millions of Americans live with debt they cannot control? That's why I developed this unique new program for managing your debt. It's called don't buy stuff you cannot afford. So we'll talk later in the conversation about why people engage in overspending, but I want to flag that if you don't understand the underlying thought patterns that lead to some of these behaviors, it can seem like the same irrational things keep happening over and over and over again. That's right.
问题的讽刺。你知道数百万美国人都在背负着无法控制的债务生活吗？这就是为什么我开发了这个独特的管理债务的新程序。它叫做“不要买你买不起的东西”。所以我们会在接下来的对话中讨论为什么人们会过度消费，但我想指出的是，如果你不了解导致其中某些行为的潜在思维模式，就会觉得同样的非理性事情在不断地、一遍又一遍地发生。没错。
And it is one of the reasons that money is the number one source of stress in the lives of Americans. Studies have shown three out of four Americans over the last 10, 15 years. It's one of the top stressors in their lives. And you can argue that we're in one of the richest wealthiest countries in the world. Hmm. So we've seen how lots of people are drawn to get rich quick schemes and to overspending, but it turns out some people have the opposite problem. One of your earliest memories involves your dad giving you a crisp $20 bill to spend at a county fair. What did you do with this
这也是金钱成为美国人生活中压力之首的原因之一。研究表明，在过去的10年、15年里，四分之三的美国人都是如此。这是他们生活中的顶级压力源之一。你可以争辩说，我们正处于世界上最富裕的国家之一。嗯。所以我们已经看到很多人是如何被快速致富的骗局和过度消费所吸引的，但事实证明，有些人有着相反的问题。你最早的记忆之一涉及到你父亲给你一张崭新的20美元钞票，让你在乡村集市上花掉。你对这笔意外之财做了什么，
windfall, Brad? Well, it did feel like a windfall. I did not have much money growing up. My parents divorced when I was about two and they were both public school teachers. So we did not have much. And when he would give me that Chris $20 bill, I felt an intense need to hoard it and to save it. And so I would go through the entire day, not buying any cotton candy and looking around at things I wanted, but feeling so good, I had that $20 bill in my pocket. Not really enjoying the money that was given to me. I was anxious about not having enough. So I have to say some listeners might say, look, this doesn't really seem like a problem. Many adults have trouble saving money. You were already saving money as a kid, why do you feel your
布拉德？嗯，这确实感觉像是一笔意外之财。我小时候没有多少钱。我两岁左右时父母离异了，他们都是公立学校的老师。所以我们没有多少钱。当他给我那张崭新的20美元钞票时，我感到了强烈的想要囤积和存起来的冲动。于是我一整天都没有买任何棉花糖，只是环顾着我想要的东西，但口袋里揣着那20美元让我感觉太美妙了。并没有真正享受给我的钱。我为拥有不够多的钱而感到焦虑。所以我必须说，有些听众可能会说，看，这其实看起来不像是个问题。许多成年人都有存钱的困难。你还是个孩子的时候就已经在存钱了，为什么你觉得你的
frugality or your hyper frugality is a problem? And perhaps you might explain that in the context of a conversation you had some time ago with your wife about a new couch. Yeah, so I think one of the problems with that mindset is you can look at it as a scarcity mindset. There's this belief and it's really deeply held almost on a cellular level that there's not enough money. And quite often if you're growing up in lower income, it's true. There really isn't enough money. But when you're able to climb that socioeconomic ladder, that thought and that emotion doesn't just disappear. And so then what you're left with is potentially an experience of scarcity and poverty, even
节俭或过度节俭是一个问题呢？也许你可以在你前段时间与妻子关于一张新沙发对话的背景下解释这一点。是的，所以我认为这种心态的问题之一在于，你可以把它看作是一种匮乏心态。有一种信念，而且在细胞层面上根深蒂固，那就是钱不够花。通常情况下，如果你在较低收入的环境中长大，这是真的。确实钱不够花。但当你能够爬上社会经济阶梯时，这种想法和情绪并不会就此消失。因此，你剩下的可能是一种匮乏和贫困的体验，尽管
though you have money and resources. And for me, what I saw happening in my life is that I felt like it was never enough. And so what I would do is I would get more and more jobs and work more and more hours. It's sort of comical when I think about it, but my wife wanted a couch and I'm about 40 years old and I had never bought a couch in my life. It's like, we don't need to buy a couch. These lawn chairs are fine. So in that moment, I realized I'm going to have to sit with my anxiety. And I got to tell you she was right because they are way more comfortable than a lawn chair.
你拥有金钱和资源。对我来说，我看到生活中发生的事情是，我觉得永远都不够。所以我就会去找越来越多的工作，工作越来越多的时间。回想起来这有点滑稽，但我妻子想要一张沙发，我当时大约40岁，我这辈子从来没买过沙发。我说，我们不需要买沙发。这些草坪椅挺好的。所以在那个时刻，我意识到我必须静下心来面对我的焦虑。我得告诉你她是对的，因为它们比草坪椅舒服多了。
We've looked at different problems that people have when it comes to money. Get rich quick schemes, spending more than we can afford, and miserliness. When we come back, the common threads that Brad has discovered that connect these different issues. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Save, avoid debt, spend less than you earn. The basic rules of money are pretty simple,
我们已经看过了人们在金钱方面遇到的各种问题。快速致富骗局、花销超出承受能力，以及吝啬。接下来的环节中，我们将探讨布拉德发现的将这些不同问题联系在一起的共同线索。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦达兰坦。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦达兰坦。存钱、避免负债、量入为出。金钱的基本规则其实很简单，
but in our day-to-day lives, many of us struggle to put these rules into practice. As a young college graduate, Brad Clons chose a risky financial path. It ended up draining his bank account. Where the dust settled, Brad asked himself a simple question, why do smart people make bad money decisions? He took it upon himself to answer that question. As a psychologist, he has spent decades studying the way we think about money. He found there are powerful influences that shape us, and the first has to do with our family history with money. Brad, I understand you are an avid martial arts fan as a kid. For your 11th birthday, your mom got you a special present. What was it? Yeah, I was so incredibly excited. I got three months of
但在我们的日常生活中，我们许多人都在努力将这些规则付诸实践。作为一个年轻的大学毕业生，布拉德·克朗茨选择了一条充满风险的财务道路。这最终导致他的银行账户被掏空。尘埃落定后，布拉德问了自己一个简单的问题：为什么聪明的人会做出糟糕的金钱决策？他把回答这个问题当成了自己的责任。作为一名心理学家，他花了几十年时间研究我们对金钱的看法。他发现有强大的影响因素在塑造着我们，而第一个因素与我们的家庭金钱历史有关。布拉德，我听说你小时候是个狂热的武术迷。为了你的11岁生日，你妈妈送了你一份特别的礼物。是什么？是的，我当时兴奋得无以复加。我得到了三个月的
cruddy lessons and then I got my white belt and it was the thing that I loved more than anything. And my gift was for three months of cruddy lessons and then when that time was up, my mom said, I'm sorry, sweetie, we don't have any more money. And it was it was actually a devastating experience for me, realizing, well, there goes the end of my martial arts training. Tell me a little bit about your mom. I understand that she was extremely frugal. Where did her anxiety about money come from?
糟糕的课程，然后我拿到了白带，这是我比什么都热爱的事物。我的礼物就是三个月的糟糕课程，然后当时间到了的时候，我妈妈说，对不起，亲爱的，我们没有钱了。这对我来说实际上是一次毁灭性的经历，我意识到，好吧，我的武术训练到此为止了。跟我聊聊你妈妈吧。据我了解她非常节俭。她对金钱的焦虑从何而来？
She went to school, or grew up in Detroit and went to high school. And she went to a high school where there was half the school was poor and the other half had money. So she was one of the poor ones and she felt extremely self-conscious about this, anxious about it. And as she's talking about it, I'm saying, oh, okay, so I get why I'm anxious. This is starting to make sense. And then I asked her, what was it like for Grandma and Grandpa growing up around money? And this blew me away. So first of all, I knew we didn't have money.
她上学，或者说是在底特律长大的并读了高中。她去的那所高中里，一半的学生很穷，另一半很有钱。所以她是穷人中的一员，她对此感到极其不自在、焦虑。当她谈到这件事时，我说，哦，好吧，那我明白为什么我会焦虑了。这开始说得通了。然后我问她，爷爷奶奶在金钱环境中长大是什么样的？这让我大吃一惊。首先，我知道我们没有钱。
And so, at this point, my grandparents, they're living in a trailer park community, so I know we didn't have much money, but I know everyone's really hard working in smart. So, this was one of the mysteries I had in my mind. And I found out that my grandfather went to the bank as a young man right during the Great Depression, and all the money was gone. And then my mom said that your grandfather never put a dollar in the bank again the rest of his life. Now, he lived into his 90s. He kept all of his money in a lock box, either in the attic or under his bed.
所以，在这个时候，我的祖父母住在拖车公园社区里，所以我知道我们没有多少钱，但我知道每个人都非常努力工作而且很聪明。所以，这是我心中的谜团之一。我发现我的祖父在年轻时，正值大萧条时期去银行，结果所有的钱都没了。然后我妈妈说，你爷爷余生再也没有往银行存过一美元。后来，他活到了90多岁。他把他所有的钱都放在一个密码箱里，要么放在阁楼里，要么放在床底下。
So you call experiences like this a financial flashpoint, an experience that leaves this long-lasting imprint on our minds. The Great Depression was clearly a financial flashpoint for a lot of people, but you argue that these financial flashpoints in some ways stay with us not just for the rest of our lives, but sometimes for the rest of our children's lives and our grandchildren's lives as well. They absolutely do, and that's what I found to be true in my own experience. I realized that my grandfather's trauma, I mean, what does that experience tell you?
所以你把这样的经历称为金融转折点，一种在我们的脑海中留下持久印记的经历。大萧条显然是许多人生命中的一个金融转折点，但你认为这些金融转折点在某些方面不仅会伴随我们余生，有时还会伴随我们孩子和孙辈的余生。它们绝对会，这也是我在自己的经历中发现的事实。我意识到我祖父的创伤，我的意思是，那段经历告诉你什么？
What do you walk away with in terms of understanding money in the world? And it's like, well, very clearly, you can't trust banks with your money. Then my mother's reticence to invest anything. She wouldn't invest in anything. She bought CDs in the bank, but she would not put money in the stock market. All of a sudden, that makes sense to me.
在理解金钱和世界方面，你从中得到了什么？很明显，你不能把钱托付给银行。然后是我母亲对投资任何东西的退缩。她什么都不投资。她在银行买存款证（CD），但绝不把钱投入股市。突然之间，这一切对我都说得通了。
And so then, this is the real light ball moment for me, is I did what I call a dysfunctional pendulum swing. You see this quite often in extreme behaviors. For example, if you grew up with an alcoholic parent, some people either become alcoholics themselves or they never touch this stuff. I went from, don't trust any financial institutions, be super conservative with your money to investing in the riskiest possible asset class. I realized if I hadn't been aware and thinking about it, I would have then swung back to that money belief my grandfather had, which is you can't trust financial institutions. What we've seen in our culture
所以，这对我来说是一个真正的顿悟时刻，我做出了我称之为“功能失调的钟摆摆动”的行为。你在极端行为中经常能看到这种现象。例如，如果你在一个有酗酒问题的父母身边长大，有些人要么自己变成酒鬼，要么对酒精碰都不碰。我从“不信任任何金融机构、对金钱超级保守”走到了“投资风险最高的资产类别”。我意识到，如果我没有意识到这一点并不去思考它，我就会摆回我祖父对金钱的信念，那就是你不能信任金融机构。我们在文化中看到的是，
is that's the typical response. And the crazy sort of creepy part is you don't even have to know the story. All you know is you have this emotional response to money. And that's what blew me away, was realizing, searching through my family history, all the sudden it made total sense why I did what I did.
这是典型的反应。而疯狂而又诡异的部分是，你甚至不需要知道这个故事。你所知道的只是你对金钱有一种情绪反应。这让我大为震撼，我意识到，在我的家族史中搜寻一番后，我为什么会做出那样的行为突然间就完全合乎情理了。
I mean, it's almost like, fuck, no risk know the past is not dead, it's not even past, that's the same idea here. And it really helped me feel less ashamed. Of course I felt ashamed and embarrassed here, I had made this financial mistake. When I put it in the context of these financial flashpoints that went back for generations in my family system, it actually freed me up a bit to give myself a break and bit to, you know, give myself a break and be like, okay, great, I made this mistake, I get why I did it, now what can I do about it? A more recent financial flashpoint might be the great recession of 2008, the housing market
我的意思是，这几乎就像是，过去并没有死，它甚至都没有过去，这完全是同一个想法。这确实帮我减少了羞耻感。我当然会感到羞耻和尴尬，我犯了这样的财务错误。当我把它置于我家族系统中历经几代的金融转折点的背景下时，它实际上让我释怀了一些，让我放自己一马，让我，你知道的，放自己一马并想：好吧，太棒了，我犯了这个错误，我明白我为什么这么做了，现在我能做些什么呢？一个更近的金融转折点可能是2008年的大衰退，多年来一直繁荣的房地产市场
which had been booming for years suddenly crashed. Millions of people lost their homes, sparking a global economic downturn that lasted for a very long time. That downturn had a profound effect on young people. Many of them found themselves struggling to afford the things their parents owned at the same age, and Brad says even those who could afford to spend were reluctant to take financial risks. even those who could afford to spend were reluctant to take financial risks. Well, some early surveys have shown that millennials, and it makes sense, are more reticent to owning homes, to investing in the stock market.
突然崩盘。数百万人失去了家园，引发了持续了很长时间的全球经济衰退。那次经济衰退对年轻人产生了深远的影响。许多人发现自己买不起父母在他们这个年龄时拥有的东西，布拉德说，甚至那些有能力消费的人也不愿承担财务风险。甚至那些有能力消费的人也不愿承担财务风险。嗯，一些早期的调查显示，千禧一代——这合情合理——更不愿意买房，更不愿意投资股市。
I mean, as a kid, if you watch your parents have to delay retirement or lose their home, it is going to make you anxious around the thought of buying a home or investing. make you anxious around the thought of buying a home or investing. It's not just lay people who are affected by these financial flashpoints. Experts seem to be affected as well. I understand you once ran a study on how the Great Recession of 2008 changed the advice that financial planners were offering.
我的意思是，作为一个孩子，如果你看着父母不得不推迟退休或失去家园，这会让你对买房或投资的想法感到焦虑。这会让你对买房或投资的想法感到焦虑。不仅是普通人受到这些金融转折点的影响。专家似乎也受到了影响。我听说你曾经做过一项研究，关于2008年的大衰退如何改变了理财规划师提供的建议。
What did you find? Yes, so I was consulting with financial planners at the time. And in my training as a psychologist, I'd been trained at the National Center for Post-traumatic Stress in Hawaii. And so I was aware of Post-traumatic stress. And I'm talking to these advisors and I'm like, these people are traumatized. So imagine like it's not just your money,
你发现了什么？是的，我当时在为理财规划师提供咨询。在我作为心理学家的培训中，我曾在夏威夷的国家创伤后应激障碍中心受过训。所以我对创伤后应激障碍有所了解。我在和这些顾问交谈时心想：这些人都有创伤。所以想象一下，这不仅是你的钱，
but it's your parents' money and your family's money and your best friend's money that you're managing. And watching a huge drop. When we did a study, we saw that 90% of the people we surveyed had medium to severe levels of post-traumatic stress. They had trouble concentrating. They were anxious. They were worried about the future.
而且是你父母的钱、你家庭的钱以及你最好的朋友的钱，你在管理着它们。而且眼看着它们大幅下跌。当我们做一项研究时，我们发现我们调查的人中有90%达到中度到重度的创伤后应激障碍水平。他们难以集中注意力。他们很焦虑。他们对未来感到担忧。
When you experience a trauma like that, your brain tries to sort it out so that it never happens again. The other thing we saw, they were questioning their entire approach to investing, how they're helping people. Interestingly, there was a dramatic shift going on at the same time where financial advisors were moving from more of a strategic buy and hold strategy to more tactical asset management. It had a profound impact on how the investing profession was actually operating. So we've seen how these experiences, financial flashpoints, our experiences with money growing up,
当你经历这样的创伤时，你的大脑会试图理清它，以便这种事再也不会发生。我们看到的另一件事是，他们在质疑自己整个的投资方法，以及他们如何帮助人们。有趣的是，与此同时发生了一个戏剧性的转变，理财顾问们从更具战略意义的买入并持有策略转向了战术资产管理。这对理财行业的实际运作方式产生了深远的影响。所以我们已经看到这些经历——金融转折点、我们成长过程中与金钱的经历、
even the way our parents and grandparents thought about money. All these things influenced the way we think about money. In our minds, they form what you call money scripts. What do you mean by that term, Brad? So money scripts is the term that we use to describe beliefs about money that we quite often inherit from our grandparents and our great grandparents and the culture and the people around us and events that are happening. And I use the word scripts because
甚至我们的父母和祖父母对金钱的看法——所有这些事情都影响了我们对金钱的看法。在我们的脑海中，它们形成了你所说的“金钱剧本”。布拉德，你这个术语是什么意思？所以“金钱剧本”是我们用来描述对金钱的信念的术语，这些信念我们往往是从我们的祖父母、曾祖父母、文化、我们周围的人以及正在发生的事件中继承来的。我用“剧本”这个词是因为
they're almost like a script written in a play, you know, that was passed down to me. And I don't even know who the author was. I don't know what they were thinking. All I know is I have these beliefs around money that are banging around in my subconscious. And in our studies, we have found that these beliefs, most of us aren't even really aware of them. They have a profound impact on our financial outcomes, like our income, our net worth, our financial behaviors, our credit card debt. And so I think it's really important to be aware of your money scripts.
它们几乎就像戏剧中写好的剧本一样，你知道的，传给了我。我甚至不知道作者是谁。我不知道他们在想什么。我只知道我有一些关于金钱的信念在我的潜意识里盘旋。在我们的研究中，我们发现这些信念——我们大多数人甚至都没有真正意识到它们——对我们的财务结果有着深远的影响，比如我们的收入、净资产、财务行为、信用卡债务。所以我认为意识到你的金钱剧本真的非常重要。
So your money script came from growing up in a household where having enough money was a struggle, but there are other scripts that also come from growing up poor or watching your parents fight about money or being around other people who are in dire straits. And let's look at some of those other scripts. One is something that you call money avoidance. Can you describe for me what this is? So money avoidance is a pattern of beliefs that make you have some anxiety or negative associations with money.
所以你的金钱剧本来自于在一个金钱艰难的家庭中长大，但还有其他剧本也来自于在贫困中长大、看父母为钱争吵或身处水深火热之中。让我们来看看其中一些其他的剧本。一个是你们称之为“金钱回避”的东西。你能为我描述一下这是什么吗？所以金钱回避是一种信念模式，它会让你对金钱产生一些焦虑或负面联想。
And specifically, their beliefs like rich people are greedy, money corrupts, or there's virtue in living with less money. And this is actually not an uncommon belief pattern in lower income communities and environments because quite often the thing about money scripts, they all are valid in a certain context. So without a doubt, you can find people who are rich, who are total jerks, and do terrible things in the world.
具体来说，诸如“富人是贪婪的”、“金钱会腐蚀人心”或者“过少钱的生活是一种美德”这样的信念。这实际上在低收入社区和环境中并不是一种罕见的信念模式，因为金钱剧本的一个特点是，它们在特定语境下都是有效的。毫无疑问，你能找到既富有又是彻头彻尾的混蛋、在世界上做可怕事情的人。
And that's the tricky thing about money scripts is there's always an element of truth. But this belief set, when we study it, it damages the world. And that's the tricky thing about money scripts is there's always an element of truth. But this belief set, when we study it, it damages the holder. Like people who have these beliefs and believe them very strongly are much more likely to have lower income, lower net worth, and engage in self-destructive financial behaviors because they have a negative association with money. It's a lot easier to adopt a belief that having money is bad and rich people are evil, you can do that a lot faster than you can go become rich, which can take decades or generations.
这就是金钱剧本棘手的地方，因为总有一部分是真的。但当我们研究这套信念时，它会伤害持有者。比如那些有这些信念并且坚信不疑的人，更有可能拥有较低的收入、较低的净资产，并从事自我毁灭性的金融行为，因为他们对金钱有负面的联想。采纳“有钱是坏事、富人是恶魔”这种信念要容易得多，这比你变成富人要快得多——后者可能需要几十年或几代人的时间。
And so if you want to feel better instantly, the bailout is to vilify the people who have something that you wish you had. The opposite of money avoidance is another money script. This one is called money worship. This money script also affects people who grew up without much money. What are the hallmarks of money worship, Brett? Yeah, money worship, I would say, could potentially be the average American. It's beliefs that more money and more stuff is going to make me happier and it's going
因此，如果你想立刻感觉好点，最简单的逃避方式就是将那些拥有你希望拥有的东西的人妖魔化。与金钱回避相反的是另一个金钱剧本。这个被称为“金钱崇拜”。这个金钱剧本也会影响那些在不太富裕的环境中长大的人。布拉德，金钱崇拜的特征是什么？是的，金钱崇拜，可以说，可能代表了平均水平的美国人。这种信念认为，更多的钱和更多的东西会让我更快乐，它将
to solve all of my problems. Now, the crazy part is in our studies, there is a very strong correlation between people who hate money and also wish they were rich. Now, just to illustrate the confusion that so many of us have around money, they're very, very much in conflict, but that's a common pattern we see. And if you believe that more money,
解决我所有的烦恼。现在，疯狂的部分在于，在我们的研究中，那些痛恨金钱同时也渴望变得富有的人之间存在着非常强的相关性。现在，为了说明我们许多人对金钱感到的困惑，它们是非常非常冲突的，但这确实是我们看到的常见模式。如果你相信更多的钱、
more stuff's going to make you happier. First of all, there's an element of truth in that. If you're growing up hungry and poor and you can't afford karate lessons and you love them, having more money will help. And if you're able to use some money to better your life and give you better experiences, I think it's a beautiful thing.
更多的东西会让你更快乐。首先，这其中包含着一部分真实情况。如果你在饥饿和贫困中长大，负担不起你热爱却又学不起的空手道课程，拥有更多的钱会有所帮助。如果你能够用一些钱来改善你的生活并带给你更好的体验，我认为这是一件美好的事情。
But if you're putting money on a pedestal, there's no amount of purchases of things that are going to make you happy in any sort of sustainable way. Another script that you talk about is something called Money Status. People who follow the script place a lot of value on money. So unlike money avoiders, they are willing to say that money is important, but you say they confuse their net worth with their self-worth. What do you mean by that? So in some ways, we have shown that the keeping up with the Jones's effect is actually real and it actually happens. And this is where people would, if you ask
但如果你把金钱放在神坛上，无论购买多少东西都无法以任何可持续的方式让你真正快乐。你谈到的另一个剧本叫做“金钱地位”。遵循这个剧本的人对金钱赋予了很高的价值。因此，与金钱回避者不同，他们愿意承认金钱很重要，但你说他们把净资产和自我价值混为一谈了。这是什么意思？在某种程度上，我们已经证明了“与邻居攀比”的效应实际上是真实存在的，而且它确实会发生。这就是人们会做的事情，如果你问
them how much they made, they would probably tell you they make more than they actually do. They don't want to buy something unless it's new. They really want to show the world that they have status, that they have value, that they have importance. And unfortunately, of course, this can lead to overspending, and there's another huge problem with it. Our culture lies to us about how rich people actually spend their money. And the money status scripts, you see it all over the place, like Instagram, TikTok, all the social media platforms sell this idea that rich people have outward
他们赚了多少钱，他们可能会告诉你他们赚的其实比实际要多。除非是新的，否则他们什么都不想买。他们真的很想向世界展示他们有地位、有价值、有重要性。不幸的是，当然，这会导致过度消费，而且它还有一个巨大的问题。我们的文化对富人实际如何花钱这件事撒了谎。而金钱地位剧本，你到处都能看到，比如Instagram、TikTok，所有社交媒体平台都在兜售这样一种观念，即富人有外在的
displays of wealth. And certainly, there are people who are wealthy who spend money quite lavishly, and there's nothing wrong with that if you can afford it. That is just not how most wealthy people spend their money. First of all, most millionaires in the US are self-made in the sense that they didn't inherit all the money. So how do you become wealthy and how do you grow your net worth? Well, it's actually by saving and by investing and not by buying the latest flashy thing
财富展示。当然，确实有一些富有的人花钱相当阔绰，如果你负担得起，这并没有错。但这只是大多数富人花钱的方式吗？首先，美国的大多数百万富翁都是白手起家的，这意味着他们并没有继承所有的钱。那么你如何变得富有以及如何增加你的净资产呢？嗯，实际上是通过储蓄和投资，而不是通过购买最新、最炫耀的东西
to try to impress your friends. You know, I'm thinking about that book that came out some years ago, The Millionaire Next Door, and it was all about how the people who are next door living very ordinary lives, you know, driving, you know, 12-year-old cars and, you know, not even very expensive cars. These are the people who are truly wealthy. Many of the wealthiest people, in fact, are living fairly modest lives. Can you talk about that idea, Brad, that in some ways there's a disconnect between what we see in the media, the representations of who we think are rich and who is actually rich in our society.
来试图给你的朋友留下深刻印象。你知道的，我想到了几年前出版的那本书《邻家的百万富翁》，它讲述的全是那些住在隔壁过着非常普通生活的人，你知道的，开着12年旧的车，而且你知道的，甚至不是什么非常昂贵的车。这些人才是真正的富人。事实上，许多最富有的人过着相当简朴的生活。布拉德，你能谈谈这个想法吗？即在某些方面，我们在媒体上看到的、关于我们认为谁是富人的形象，与我们社会中谁才是真正的富人之间存在着脱节。
Yes, one of the most profound things about the millionaire next door is it took our vision of who rich people are and how they live their life and it just turned it on its head. And if there's such profound wisdom in that, because if you live the life that you think most wealthy people are living, you're going to get a paycheck and then you're going to start buying watches, expensive cars, feeling like this is what you need to do to join that group. That is actually the opposite of what most millionaires do in the United States. So all the scripts that we've talked about so far seem like, you know, they're pretty
是的，《邻家的百万富翁》最深刻的地方之一在于，它彻底颠覆了我们对富人是谁以及他们如何生活的愿景。其中蕴含着如此深刻的智慧，因为如果你过着你认为大多数富人所过的生活，你拿到工资后就会开始买手表、昂贵的汽车，觉得这是你加入那个群体所必须做的事情。这实际上与美国大多数百万富翁的做法背道而驰。所以到目前为止我们谈论的所有剧本看起来都挺
bad. They produce problems in people's lives. Are they scripts that actually point to good money habits? You know, thankfully there are, right? And scripts we can aspire to. And so what we call those in our studies, we call them money vigilance. And this is the group of people in our culture that have the most money. They fight with
糟糕的。它们给人们的生活带来了问题。有没有哪些剧本实际上指向良好的金钱习惯呢？你知道的，谢天谢地，是有的，对吧？还有我们可以效仿的剧本。我们在研究中称之为“金钱警惕”。这是我们文化中拥有最多钱的一群人。他们与
their spouse the least, they have more income, and their beliefs like it's important to save for a rainy day. I'd be a nervous wreck if I didn't have money save for an emergency. So there's that real emphasis on saving and investing is important. There's a future orientation and a little bit of anxiety associated with it.
配偶的争吵最少，收入更高，他们的信念比如“为雨天存钱很重要”。如果我没有为紧急情况存钱，我就会变成一个神经质的 wreck（精神崩溃的人）。所以他们真正强调储蓄和投资是很重要的。有一种面向未来的导向，并伴随着一点点焦虑。
And so interestingly, if you ask them how much they made, they're actually likely to tell you they make less than they actually do, which is fascinating in terms of social media because the people who are least likely to brag about what they have are the people who tend to have the most. And in some ways, you seem like a moneyilant person yourself, but I also hear you say that perhaps this can spill over into a form of hyper anxiety, where money vigilance can become
所以有趣的是，如果你问他们赚了多少钱，他们实际上更有可能告诉你他们赚得比实际要少，这在社交媒体时代非常迷人，因为最不可能吹嘘自己拥有什么的人，往往正是那些拥有最多的人。在某种程度上，你自己看起来就是一个对金钱保持警惕的人，但我也听到你说，也许这会蔓延成一种过度焦虑的形式，金钱警惕可能会变成
hypervigilance, and then you become unable to spend money even when you can afford it. Yeah, actually, my first book I wrote about Ebenezer Scrooge. Ebenezer Scrooge is the perfect example of a hyper-vigilant ultra-wealthy individual. And the problem was, he had a scarcity mindset. Now what is so fascinating about that mindset is if you grow up in poverty and not having enough, it can make you an incredibly hard worker. Some of the richest people I know were immigrants who had nothing. And their work ethic was so incredible, but they were so anxious about not having enough. They can have a difficult time enjoying life.
过度警惕，然后即使你负担得起，你也变得无法花钱了。是的，事实上，我的第一本书写的就是埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇（Ebenezer Scrooge）。埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇就是过度警惕、极端富有的个人的完美例子。问题是，他有一种匮乏心态。这种心态最迷人的地方在于，如果你在贫困和物资匮乏的环境中长大，它会让你变得极其刻苦。我认识的一些最富有的人都是一无所有的移民。他们的职业道德令人难以置信，但他们对拥有不够多的钱感到非常焦虑。他们可能很难真正享受生活。
And so that's really we need to be able to do both. We need to be able to save for the future and enjoy the moment. I'm also reflecting that money scripts in some ways teach us to be vigilant to the kinds of things that produced trauma in our past or in our family's past. But unfortunately, money traumas are not like the trauma of encountering a predator, where you just want to stay clear of the predator.
所以，这确实是我们两方面都需要做到的。我们需要为未来存钱，也要享受当下。我也在反思，金钱剧本在某种程度上教导我们要保持警惕，防范那些在我们的过去或家族过去中造成创伤的事物。但不幸的是，金钱创伤不像遭遇捕食者的创伤那样，你只需要避开捕食者就行了。
If you lost all your money in the Great Depression, but now you're choosing to stick your money under your mattress or in the attic, you're solving a trauma that was in the past, even as you're exposing yourself to the risk of an even bigger trauma in the future. So in some ways, it makes sort of, it sort of, it makes intuitive sense why we would have these scripts, but in actual practice, they could be deeply destructive. That's right. And in my experience, the ones that are the most difficult to change and shift are the ones that have intense emotion attached to them. So the example of my grandfather, it wasn't just this thought, oh, you shouldn't trust banks because beliefs can change very easily. When the federal government came in
如果你在大萧条时期失去了所有的钱，但现在你选择把钱塞在床垫底下或阁楼里，你是在解决过去的一个创伤，哪怕你正让自己暴露在未来更大创伤的风险之中。所以在某种程度上，我们为什么会有这些剧本，这在直觉上是说得通的，但在实际做法中，它们可能是极具破坏性的。没错。根据我的经验，那些最难改变和转变的剧本，都是附带着强烈情感的剧本。所以以我祖父为例，这不仅仅是一种想法，哦，你不应该信任银行，因为信念是很容易改变的。当联邦政府介入
and guaranteed banks, well, I guess what? Now you can trust them, but that emotion was so intense. And so when we have really emotional experiences or they go back in our family for generations around money, that's when it can become really difficult to change our relationship with money. This is where we find ourselves knowing that we shouldn't be doing things, but finding ourselves continuing to do it. Our experiences are upbringing and our financial background, all play a role in how we think and behave when it comes to money. Because these scripts are so deeply ingrained, our problems with money can seem impossible to solve. When we come back, how to change that?
并为银行提供担保时，结果呢？现在你可以信任它们了，但那种情感是如此强烈。因此，当我们有非常情绪化的经历，或者这些经历在我们的家族中围绕金钱延续了几代人时，这就是改变我们与金钱的关系变得非常困难的时候。正是在这里，我们发现自己明知不该做某些事情，却又发现自己仍在继续这样做。我们的经历、成长背景和财务背景，都在我们对金钱的思考和行为方式中发挥着作用。由于这些剧本根深蒂固，我们在金钱方面的问题似乎无法解决。稍后回来，如何改变这种状况？
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Brad Clans is a psychologist at Creighton University in Omaha, Nebraska. He is the author of the book Mind Over Money. He studies the thoughts, attitudes, and beliefs that people have about money. Brad calls these, are money scripts. These scripts are rooted in our past experiences with money,
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。布拉德·克兰茨是内布拉斯加州奥马哈克瑞顿大学的心理学家。他是《掌控金钱》一书的作者。他研究人们对金钱的想法、态度和信念。布拉德将这些称为我们的金钱剧本。这些剧本根植于我们过去与金钱相关的经历中，
but they determine the way we deal with money in the present and in the future. The solution to many of the problems we face with money lies in first understanding the way these scripts influence us. Once we do that, there are ways to get around these scripts or even get these scripts to work for us. Brad, I want to talk about a study you conducted where you and your colleagues went into a workplace and tried an intervention to get people to save more for retirement. You started by helping people understand their money scripts. How did you go about doing this? A big part of that was helping people identify
但它们决定了我们在现在和未来处理金钱的方式。解决我们所面临的许多金钱问题的关键，在于首先理解这些剧本是如何影响我们的。一旦我们做到了这一点，就有办法绕过这些剧本，甚至让这些剧本为我们所用。布拉德，我想谈谈你做过的一项研究，你和同事们进入一个工作场所，尝试进行一项干预，让员工为退休存更多的钱。你们首先帮助人们了解他们的金钱剧本。你们是怎么做这件事情的？其中很大一部分是帮助人们识别
their early experiences around money. And I gave them a little questionnaire on money scripts on the categories we just discussed. And then ask them to think about, what did your mom teach you about money? What did your father teach you about money? What was your earliest experiences around money? You're most joyful, you're most painful. These types of reflections are going to help you identify these underlying
他们早年围绕金钱的经历。我给他们做了一份关于金钱剧本的小问卷，涵盖了我们刚才讨论的类别。然后让他们思考：你妈妈教给你关于金钱的什么？你爸爸教给你关于金钱的什么？你最早关于金钱的经历是什么？你最快乐的经历是什么？最痛苦的经历是什么？这些类型的反思将帮助你识别这些潜在的
beliefs you have around money. And then, of course, you can then challenge and change them. As I said, every money belief, every money script, has an element of truth. And I think it's really important to validate where you learned that or where your ancestors learned that. And the most healthy mind around money is one that's flexible. So we want to be able to take in new information. So for example, my grandfather, you can trust banks, at least up to $100,000 in his time. And you need to have flexibility in thinking. So that is really the goal.
你对金钱的信念。然后，当然，你就可以挑战并改变它们。正如我所说，每一个金钱信念、每一个金钱剧本，都包含着一丝真理。我认为，去确认你是在哪里学到这一点的，或者你的祖先是在哪里学到这一点的，这真的非常重要。而对待金钱最健康的心理是具有灵活性的。所以我们希望能够吸收新的信息。例如，我的祖父，你可以信任银行，在他的时代至少可以信任到10万美元。而且你的思维需要有灵活性。所以这才是真正的目标。
I understand that contribution rates increased by about 40%, which is just an astronomical increase in the amount of money that people were saving. That's absolutely right. So that was 401k contributions. And people were had been in these meetings previously, the mandatory 401k meeting. Right. But I think really connecting with who they are, where they come from, and what they really want on the other side of this deferral, this salary deferral, really, really important. So we talked about four money scripts that produce problems. Money avoidance, money worship, money status, and hypervigilance about money. With money avoidance, people avoid dealing with money altogether because they have negative
据我了解，供款比例增加了大约40%，对于人们储蓄的金额来说，这是一个惊人的增长。完全正确。所以那是401(k)的供款。人们以前也参加过这些会议，即强制性的401(k)会议。没错。但我认为，真正与他们是谁、他们来自哪里，以及他们在这个推迟薪水、这个薪水推迟发放的决定背后真正想要的东西建立联系，这真的、真的非常重要。我们讨论了四个会产生问题的金钱剧本。金钱回避、金钱崇拜、金钱地位，以及对金钱的高度警惕。对于金钱回避，人们完全避免处理金钱，因为他们对金钱有负面的
associations with it. Money worshipers, in some ways, have the opposite problem. They overestimate how much money will buy them happiness or make them feel good about themselves. People who follow a money status script tend to focus on how having money and possessions can increase that status in the eyes of other people. So they're using money and possessions almost as a signaling device. And both people who have a money worship script and a money status script can end up doing a lot of overspending.
联想。在某种程度上，金钱崇拜者有着相反的问题。他们高估了金钱能为他们买来的幸福感，或者能让他们对自己感觉有多好。遵循金钱地位剧本的人往往关注拥有金钱和财物如何在其他人眼中提升这种地位。所以他们几乎把金钱和财物当成了一种发信号的工具。而且，拥有金钱崇拜剧本和金钱地位剧本的人，最终都可能会有大量的过度消费。
And then finally, there are people who are hyper-vigilant about money. They allow their anxieties about money, their scarcity mindset, to turn them into misers. Let's look at some of the ways we can disarm these scripts. Let's start with money avoidance. In one study where you looked at people's savings behavior, you asked people to come into a lab
最后，还有一些人对金钱保持高度警惕。他们让对金钱的焦虑、他们的稀缺心态，把他们变成守财奴。让我们来看看几种可以解除这些剧本武装的方法。让我们从金钱回避开始。在一项研究中，你观察了人们的储蓄行为，你要求人们来到实验室，
and you split them into two groups. The control group was given a financial literacy presentation. They learned some basic money management lessons on things like compound interest and saving for retirement, different kinds of banking accounts. In the experimental group, rather than give people the financial education presentation, you asked them to bring an interesting object
并将他们分成两组。对照组进行了一场金融素养演讲。他们学到了一些关于金钱管理的基本课程，比如复利、为退休储蓄以及不同类型的银行账户。在实验组中，你没有给人们进行金融教育演讲，而是让他们带一件有趣的物品
into the lab with them. What kind of objects do you ask people to bring, and why did you ask them to do this? We asked people to bring in something they had saved, a sentimental object. Maybe it was something they got from a grandparents, people brought in pieces of jewelry, some people brought in stuffed animals, some people brought in pictures of vacations they took as kids, and what we were trying to do was get people connected to their core values. What really matters to them? And what was this intervention designed to do? How does that help change their behavior when it comes to money? From my perspective, I was theorizing that
来到实验室。你让人们带什么样 Objet（物品）来，为什么让他们这样做？我们让人们带了一件他们一直保存的东西，一件有纪念意义的物品。也许那是他们从祖父母那里得到的东西，有人带了首饰，有人带了毛绒玩具，有人带了他们小时候度假的照片，而我们试图做的是让人们与他们的核心价值观建立联系。什么对他们来说真正重要？这项干预措施旨在达到什么目的？这如何帮助改变他们在金钱方面的行为？从我的角度来看，我的理论是，
if we could get people in touch with what really matters to them in a visceral way, that's why I wanted it to be very experiential, not just think about it, but bring in the item. I had people close their eyes and think about how this item came into their life, how it felt, what it meant to them to really get at these core values.
如果我们能以一种直观的方式让人们接触到对他们真正重要的是什么，这就是为什么我希望它是高度体验式的，不仅仅是去思考它，而是把物品带过来。我让人们闭上眼睛，思考这个物品是如何进入他们的生活的，它的感觉如何，对他们意味着什么，从而真正触及这些核心价值观。
And then what I did is I had them identify their values. Like, so what does this represent to you? It represents family, safety, adventure, comfort. And then I use that as a bridge to have them identify their top three financial goals. And they look like a kindergarten classroom. We had paper, we had scissors, we had people drawing pictures, cutting out pictures, really getting a very clear vision
然后我做的是让他们识别自己的价值观。比如，这代表了什么？它代表了安全感、家庭、冒险、舒适。然后我以此为桥梁，让他们确定他们最重要的三个财务目标。他们看起来像个幼儿园教室。我们有纸，有剪刀，我们有人在画画，剪下图片，真正获得一个非常清晰的愿景：
of why they want to save for the future. So I can imagine that if someone is a money avoider, they have negative associations with money, they don't want to deal with it at all, they want to push thoughts of money out of their heads, connecting money to their personal values might help them in some ways rewrite or rethink that script.
为什么他们想要为未来储蓄。所以我可以想象，如果一个人是金钱回避者，他们对金钱有负面的联想，他们根本不想处理它，他们想把关于金钱的想法赶出脑海，将金钱与他们的个人价值观联系起来，可能在某种程度上帮助他们重写或重新思考那个剧本。
That's right. So we expose them to the idea and try to encourage them to explore the idea that not all money is bad. Because the belief that rich people are greedy and money corrupts is accurate in only one context. It's much more accurate to say, some rich people do bad things in the world. I can become wealthy and do good things in the world.
没错。所以我们将他们暴露在这个想法中，并试图鼓励他们去探索这样一个概念：并非所有的金钱都是坏的。因为“富人是贪婪的，金钱是腐蚀性的”这种信念只在一种情况下是准确的。更准确的说法是：一些有钱人在世界上做了坏事。我可以变得富有，并在世界上做好事。
And so it's really important to tackle that and examine it and to make it frankly more accurate. We were looking for more accurate thoughts. So when you connected people in some ways to things that were important in their past, perhaps made them more, I guess, emotionally available to things that had happened, the values that they cared about. And then after each experiment, you checked back in with people and looked at how much
所以解决这个问题并对其进行检查，坦率地说让它变得更准确，这真的很重要。我们在寻找更准确的想法。所以，当你把人们在某种程度上与他们过去重要的事情联系起来，也许让他们对已经发生的事情、他们关心的价值观在情感上更加敞开。然后每次实验后，你都会回访人们，看看他们
they were saving. Did you find that it made a difference in terms of increasing their savings rate? For that particular study where we had people bring in the sentimental object, we saw a 73% increase in savings as a percentage of gross income. In comparison to the 22% increase for the financial education group, but I think it really came down to getting people that are really excited. And then another hack, once you have a really clear vision of what it is you're wanting, that's when you want to automate towards those savings goals. And that's the instruction that I encouraged everyone to do. Get real excited,
存了多少钱。你发现这在提高他们的储蓄率方面有什么不同吗？对于那项让人们带入纪念品特定研究，我们看到储蓄占总收入的比例增加了73%。相比之下，金融教育组的增长率为22%，但我认为这确实归结为让人们真正感到兴奋。然后另一个诀窍是，一旦你对你想要的东西有了非常清晰的愿景，那时你就要朝那些储蓄目标实现自动化。这就是我鼓励每个人去做的那条指令。真正兴奋起来，
share this with somebody you love, and then immediately automate to capitalize on that status quo bias we have. So we've lifted some techniques to combat money avoidance. Let's look at the next money script, money worship. So these are people who believe that money or possessions can buy them happiness. I'd like to play your clip from the TV show Parks and Rec. In this scene the characters Tom and Donna are describing a special day that they have planned which involves spending a lot of money on pampering themselves. Once a year Donna and I spend a day treating ourselves. What do we treat ourselves to? Clothes. Treat yourself. Fragrance. Treat yourself. Massage it. Treat yourself. Mimosas. Treat yourself. Fine leather goods. Treat yourself. It's the best day of the year. The best day of the year. Can you
与你爱的人分享这一点，然后立即将其自动化，以利用我们所具有的现状偏差。因此，我们列举了一些对抗金钱回避的技术。让我们看看下一个金钱剧本：金钱崇拜。这些人相信金钱或财物可以为他们买来幸福。我想播放一段来自电视剧《公园与游憩》的片段。在这个场景中，角色汤姆和唐娜正在描述他们计划的一个特别日子，其中涉及花很多钱来犒劳自己。一年中的某一天，我和唐娜会花上一天时间来犒劳自己。我们犒劳自己什么？衣服。犒劳自己。香水。犒劳自己。按摩。犒劳自己。含羞草鸡尾酒。犒劳自己。优质皮具。犒劳自己。这是一年中最棒的一天。一年中最棒的一天。你能
explain what you found about how you can disrupt the script by changing patterns of behavior? So part of it comes down to educating people around happiness in general. So happiness is a state, right? It's not a trait. It's not like you're either happy or you're not happy. It's like you're going to be happy 10 times today and you're going to be sad 10 times today. And so realizing that stuff is not the cure to happiness. And I love the example of thinking to your birthday as a kid and you got this shiny new toy.
解释一下，关于如何通过改变行为模式来打破这个剧本，你发现了什么吗？所以其中一部分归结为向人们普及普遍的幸福感。所以幸福是一种状态，对吧？它不是一种特质。并不是说你要么快乐，要么不快乐。这就像你今天会快乐10次，也会悲伤10次。所以认识到物质并不是通往幸福的解药。我喜欢这样的例子：想想你小时候过生日时，你得到了这个闪亮的新玩具。
I mean, this thing you always wanted, you know, that red rider BB gun. Have you been happy ever since then? I mean, did that thing create happiness in your life? Of course not. It's fleeting. The emotion is fleeting. And so I really identifying that money in and of itself and items in and of itself are not the key to happiness. So the third problem we looked at was the script of money status. You found that people who follow the script prioritize outward displays of wealth and they often end up with a lot of debt. How can people learn to combat this script, Brad?
我的意思是，这个你一直想要的东西，你知道，那把红骑手气枪。从那以后你一直都很开心吗？我的意思是，那东西在你的生活中创造了幸福吗？当然没有。它是短暂的。这种情绪是短暂的。所以我真正认识到，金钱本身以及物品本身并不是通往幸福的关键。我们看过的第三个问题是金钱地位剧本。你发现遵循这个剧本的人优先考虑对财富的外在展示，他们往往会背负大量债务。人们如何能学会对抗这个剧本，布拉德？
One study that we did, we saw people from an ultra-networth group and we compared them to a middle-class group. The ultra-wealthy had about a net worth of about $10 million and we compared them to a group people who had a net worth of about $500,000. What was so interesting about this study is that ultra-networth group, they had about 18 times more money, but they only spent twice as much as that middle class group on their watch, their house, their car, and their last vacation. And so for me, a huge part of it is educating people on if you really do want to have
我们做过的一项研究中，我们观察了一个超级资产净值群体，并将他们与中产阶级群体进行了比较。超级富豪的净资产大约为1000万美元，我们将他们与净资产约为50万美元的人群进行了比较。这项研究非常有趣的地方在于，那个超级资产净值群体，他们的钱大约多出18倍，但在手表、房子、汽车和上一次度假上，他们花在中产阶级群体身上的钱只有两倍。所以对大我来说，其中很大一部分是向人们普及，如果你真的想要拥有
quote status and have wealth, this is how you need to operate and this is how you need to get there. It's actually the opposite of what you're seeing people do on social media. Those people are quite often trying to do a brand deal or they're selling you a course or a get rich quick scheme. That is not how most people become wealthy. And it makes logical sense. They become wealthy by growing their net worth, not getting rid of their net worth. We talked earlier about how money scripts can produce interpersonal conflict, conflict
所谓的地位并拥有财富，这就是你需要运作的方式，也是你需要到达那里的方式。这实际上与你在社交媒体上看到人们做的事情相反。这些人经常试图做一个品牌交易，或者他们向你出售一门课程或快速致富的计划。大多数人并不是这样变得富有的。而且这在逻辑上是说得通的。他们通过增加净资产而不是摆脱净资产来变得富有。我们前面讨论过金钱剧本如何产生人际冲突，冲突
within marriages, within families, within households. I'm wondering how you have tried to resolve this yourself in your own relationship, perhaps with your wife or with other people in your family, but also more generally, how people can resolve problems with their money scripts that are not just rooted in themselves, but are rooted in relationships and interpersonal behavior. Well quite simply, I have spent 20 years convention my wife that she's wrong about everything around money and that her parents were wrong and her grandparents were wrong.
发生在婚姻内部、家庭内部、住户内部。我想知道你是如何尝试在自己的关系中解决这个问题的，也许是与你的妻子或你家里的其他人，但也更广泛地说，人们如何能够解决他们的金钱剧本问题，这些问题不仅植根于他们自己，而且植根于关系和人际行为中。很简单，我花了20年时间说服我的妻子，她在关于金钱的一切事情上都是错的，她的父母是错的，她的祖父母也是错的。
This is what most couples do actually. They're unconsciously battling it out. If you're not careful, the conflict is going to push you further and further apart. And before you know it, you're going to be saying some ridiculous things. Like, we only should live in lawn chairs, you know, not couches, you know, because you're so worried about your partner spending. So when couples go to counseling and therapy on average, the ones who go to a therapist have been fighting about an issue for seven years. So when I work with couples in conflict,
这其实是大多数夫妻所做的。他们在无意识地争斗。如果你不小心，冲突会把你们推得越来越远。在你意识到之前，你会说出一些荒谬的话。比如，我们只应该坐在折叠椅上生活，你知道的，而不是沙发上，因为你太担心你的伴侣花钱了。所以当夫妻去寻求咨询和治疗时，平均而言，去求助治疗师的夫妻已经为一个问题争吵了七年了。所以当我与处于冲突中的夫妻合作时，
what I have them do is table that, whatever this issue is. Like, we'll get to the, by the way, that's the easy part is fixing that. But what we should really do is have a conversation that you all should have had on date seven. Okay, now we could debate which date number it is, but you know, about the date where you're saying, hey, do you want wanna have kids someday?
我让他们做的是把那个问题搁置起来，无论这个话题是什么。比如，我们会解决的，顺便说一下，那是最容易的部分，解决那个很简单。但我们真正应该做的是进行一次你们本该在第七次约会时就进行的对话。好吧，现在我们可以争论到底是第几次约会了，但你知道的，关于那个约会的谈话，你当时会说，嘿，你以后想要孩子吗？
Where do you wanna live? We don't talk about money. We don't talk about what are your financial goals? How do you handle money? How do you wanna handle money? And so I encourage couples to just rewind to date number seven, sit down and have a conversation. And some of those questions are,
你想住在哪里？我们不谈论金钱。我们不谈论你的财务目标是什么。你如何处理金钱？你想如何处理金钱？所以我鼓励夫妻倒带回到第七次约会，坐下来进行一次对话。其中一些问题是：
what was it like for you growing up around money? What did your mom teach you? What did your mom teach you? What did your dad teach you? What is your most painful money experience? Your most joyful money experience? What are your financial goals? What are your financial fears? I love this one too.
你在金钱环境中长大是什么感觉？你妈妈教了你什么？你妈妈教了你什么？你爸爸教了你什么？你最痛苦的金钱经历是什么？你最快乐的金钱经历是什么？你的财务目标是什么？你的财务恐惧是什么？我也很喜欢这个：
How did you feel about your socioeconomic class growing up? And then I also asked them to say, you know, what are my most proud of in my relationship with money? And what do I appreciate about you, my partner, around money? And what I have found is that this has two benefits. People get insight about their own relationship with money. And then I get insight about my partner's relationship with money. And so, for example, I might have seen some irrational spending that made no sense to me. Now I see that my partner grew up not having much.
你对成长过程中的社会经济阶层有何感受？然后我还让他们说，你知道，在我和金钱的关系中，我最自豪的是什么？在金钱方面，我欣赏你（我的伴侣）什么？我发现这有两个好处。人们对他们自己与金钱的关系有了深入的了解。然后我了解了我伴侣与金钱的关系。所以，例如，我可能见过一些毫无意义的非理性消费。现在我看到我的伴侣在成长过程中没有拥有太多。
And for them, whatever that purchase was, was almost this desperate sort of need to say, it's okay, I can actually have some things because I grew up with nothing. And if I can look at it through that lens, I have much more compassion and it's much more easier for us to negotiate a solution around whatever this thing it was we were fighting about. You know, as you're talking, Brad, I'm realizing that one reason I think many people don't
对他们而言，无论那笔消费是什么，几乎都是一种绝望的需求，想要表达：没关系，我其实可以拥有一些东西，因为我长大时一无所有。如果我能透过那个视角来看待它，我就会有更多的同情心，我们也就更容易围绕我们正在争吵的这件任何事情协商出一个解决方案。你知道，在你说话的时候，布拉德，我意识到许多人之所以不
do this, and perhaps don't think to do this is, is that many of these conversations involve the emotion of shame. And especially when it comes to money, people have grown up, especially if you're grown up poor, or especially if you're grown musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician,
这样做，也许根本没想到要这样做的原因之一，就是许多此类对话都带有羞耻感。特别是当谈到金钱时，人们在成长过程中，特别是如果你在贫困中长大，或者特别是如果你成长为一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，
you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, you're a musician, things make our scripts invisible not just to other people, but invisible to ourselves. That's right. Shame is an emotional glue trap and it keeps us stuck in our financial behaviors. And so, deshaming is so important. And part of what I'm talking about, I can take any baby born and I could probably stick them in your family, stick them in your culture, give them the experiences you had, and they'd be thinking and behaving exactly the way you are around money. So, shame does us no good at all, and when we're shaming each other in relationships,
你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，你是一名音乐家，这些事情让我们的剧本不仅对其他人隐形，对我们自己也隐形了。没错。羞耻感是一种情感上的强力胶陷阱，它让我们陷入财务行为中无法自拔。因此，消除羞耻感是如此重要。我所谈论的一部分是，我可以带走任何出生的婴儿，我大概可以把他们塞进你的家庭，塞进你的文化，让他们经历你所经历的经历，他们对金钱的思考和行为方式就会和你一模一样。所以，羞耻感对我们一点好处也没有，当我们在关系中互相羞耻时，
it's terrible. I think it's really great to start with, we're all screwed up when it comes to money, so let's all move forward. How does it speak to people who might be currently in very difficult financial straight. So let's say someone's working minimum wage job. They're not able to make ends meet. And they hear this conversation and they say, well, it's all very well for you to talk
这太糟糕了。我认为一个非常棒的起点是：我们在金钱方面都很混乱，所以让我们一起向前迈进。这对于目前可能处于非常困难的财务困境中的人来说意味着什么？比方说，有人在做最低工资的工作。他们无法维持生计。他们听到这段对话，然后说，好吧，你谈论
about money scripts and what I should be doing psychologically. But I just, I'm not getting paid enough. I just don't make enough. Are money scripts or the conversations about money scripts and the psychology of money? Is this a conversation primarily for people who are well off? Or do you think people who are poor have something to gain from this conversation as well? I'll be honest, I'm not that worried about trying to help people who are well off. That's not really why I do the research I do. I believe money scripts are most important for people who are struggling financially,
金钱剧本以及我在心理上应该做的事情，这都很好。但我只是，我没有得到足够的薪水。我只是挣得不够。金钱剧本或者关于金钱剧本和金钱心理学的对话，这主要是一场针对富裕人群的对话吗？还是你认为穷人也能从这场对话中获得一些东西？老实说，我并不是那么担心去帮助富裕的人。那并不是我做研究的真正原因。我相信金钱剧本对那些在财务上苦苦挣扎的人最重要，
for people who are poor and low income and working class. I think they're the ones who can benefit the most from understanding their money scripts. And it's not just understanding, oh, I have these beliefs. There's another very key element, and that is challenging them and changing them, and realizing that these beliefs predict income.
对于穷人、低收入人群和工人阶级来说。我认为他们才是最能从理解自己的金钱剧本中受益的人。这不仅仅是理解“哦，我有这些信念”。还有一个非常关键的要素，那就是挑战它们、改变它们，并认识到这些信念可以预测收入。
They predict not worth. They have a profound impact on your relationship with money for the rest of your life. And so understanding though that a part of why you are where you are is just a stroke of fate. You can't help where you were born. You can't help what family system you were born in, but understanding that you have the ability and the power to examine those beliefs, to modify and change them
它们可以预测净资产。它们对你余生与金钱的关系有着深远的影响。因此，理解你之所以处于现在的境地，部分原因只是命运的捉弄。你无法选择你在哪里出生。你无法选择你出生在什么样的家庭系统里，但你要明白，你有能力和权力去审视这些信念，去修改和改变它们，
so you can better your life. The studies we have done have found that people who have more money are more likely to have an internal locus control, believing that the mistakes in their life are because of them. The successes are because of what they're doing and they have the power to change their life. And so that's a message that I think is great
这样你就能改善你的生活。我们做过的研究发现，拥有更多钱的人更有可能具有内在控制点，他们认为生活中的错误是由于他们自己造成的。成功是由于他们所做的事情，他们有能力改变自己的生活。所以我认为这是一个很棒的信息，
for everybody, especially people who are struggling financially. I'm wondering if you can tell me about a time when your own study and research into money scripts helped you revise or even recognize that you were operating under a money script and perhaps give you the latitude to change what it is that you were doing. So for me, part of understanding my money scripts was a conversation that I had with my father and my wife was sitting there at the time.
对每个人来说都是如此，尤其是对那些在财务上苦苦挣扎的人。我想知道你能否告诉我，你自己的金钱剧本研究和调查帮助你修正甚至认识到你正处在一个金钱剧本的运作之下，并且也许给了你改变你正在做的事情的自由度的一次经历？对我和来说，理解我的金钱剧本的一部分是我与父亲的一次对话，当时我的妻子正坐在旁边。
And I said that I had worked 70 hours the past week, but I felt lazy compared to him. And my father said, I worked 100 hours and I feel lazy compared to him. And my father said, I worked a hundred hours and I feel lazy compared to my dad, so which is my grandpa. And I was like, what? I said, dad, why? He goes, well, I don't know if you know this. And by the way, I didn't know this,
我说我过去一周工作了70个小时，但与他相比我觉得自己很懒。我父亲说，我工作了100个小时，但与他相比我觉得自己很懒。我父亲说，我工作了一百个小时，但与我想象中比我爸（也就是我爷爷）相比，我觉得自己很懒。我当时就想：什么？我说，爸，为什么？他说，嗯，我不知道你知不知道这件事。顺便说一句，我当时并不知道，
but my grandfather's father was a lazy good for nothing. And my grandfather had lived his entire life trying to please his mother by being a hard worker and supporting her. And my dad is here working a hundred hours a week trying to, you know, live up to his father's standards. And I'm feeling guilty working 70 hours a week. I got to tell you when I saw that pattern, I laughed. I thought it was crazy. I can't believe I'm living out this script that goes back for generations and has nothing to do with my life. All I know is that I'm not
但我爷爷的父亲是一个一无是处的懒汉。我爷爷一生都在试图通过做一个努力工作并支持母亲的人来取悦母亲。而我父亲在这里每周工作一百个小时，试图，你知道的，达到他父亲的标准。而我因为每周工作70个小时而感到内疚。我得告诉你，当我看到那个模式时，我笑了。我觉得这太疯狂了。我不敢相信我正在上演这个延续了数代人且与我的生活毫无关系的剧本。我只知道我没有
taking care of myself. I'm not spending as much time as I want to with my wife. I know I don't want to be an absent father like my father and my grandfather profound understanding for me, but I'm gonna tell you this. It was so hardwired that I had to write a script for myself and read it at the end of the workday that said this. I have worked enough today. My family and my health is more important to me than this job. I'm getting up and I'm going home.
照顾好自己。我没有花尽可能多的时间陪伴我的妻子。我知道我不想成为像我父亲和爷爷那样缺席的父亲，这对我来说是一个深刻的理解，但我必须告诉你：它是如此根深蒂固，以至于我不得不为自己写一个剧本，并在工作日结束时朗读它，上面写着：我今天已经工作够了。我的家庭和我的健康对我来说比这份工作更重要。我要站起来回家。
I literally had to read that to myself for at least a year to try to change that money belief. Brad Klantz is a psychologist at Creighton University. He is a co-founder of the Financial Psychology Institute, and he's the author of Mind Over Money, overcoming the money disorders that threaten our financial health. Brad, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Right. It was my pleasure, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was my pleasure, thank you so much. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
我真的不得不对自己朗读这番话至少一年，试图改变那种金钱信念。布拉德·克兰茨是克瑞顿大学的心理学家。他是金融心理学研究所的联合创始人，也是《掌控金钱：战胜威胁我们财务健康的金钱失调症》一书的作者。布拉德，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这是我的荣幸，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这是我的荣幸，非常感谢。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is David Biello. If you've watched a recent science-related TED Talk, you have David to thank for it. David is the science curator at TED, and he was by my side recently as I delivered my first TED Talk.
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯滕·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥本·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是大卫·别洛。如果你看过最近与科学相关的 TED 演讲，你就得感谢大卫。大卫是 TED 的科学策展人，当我最近发表我的第一场 TED 演讲时，他一直陪在我身边。
David's wise feedback and guidance were invaluable throughout the process, and I'm really grateful to him. I expect my TED Talk will be posted soon. Thank you, David. Hundreds of Hidden Brain listeners have stepped up to make a contribution to support our work. If you like the show, please consider joining them. You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org.
在大卫的整个过程中，他睿智的反馈和指导是极其宝贵的，我对他非常感激。我预计我的 TED 演讲很快就会发布。谢谢你，大卫。成百上千的《隐藏的大脑》听众挺身而出，为支持我们的工作做出贡献。如果你喜欢这个节目，请考虑加入他们。你可以在 support.hiddenbrain.org 上这样做。
Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. Next week on our Money 2.0 series, how to avoid the mental traps we often fall into when it comes to our spending. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次重申，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org。下周我们的“金钱 2.0”系列将探讨：如何避免我们在金钱支出方面经常陷入的心理陷阱。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。